hi everyone it's joanna here so today
we'll be breaking down the foundation of
doing lower body workouts so the
exercises will be targeting specifically
on your quads your glutes as well as
your hamstrings sometimes when we do a
workout we might not know exactly which
muscle group we're targeting so that's
what we will be focusing and learning
today this workout will be low impact
and it will be slow in pace so let's get
started
so let's start with a quick warm-up to
prep our lower body so remember to
always stand in a neutral position hips
toes pointed forward shoulder width
apart okay so let's start with few hip
circles
really to prep our hip joints as well as
our legs
good so hip circles
one way and now let's go the opposite
direction
okay
big circles pushing your butt back and
your hips forward
good and now few hip openers so final
balance
let's start on the left side
pushing your knees out to the side
and back in the center okay so really
opening up your hip flexor
good
few more up and open now change the
other side okay
as high as you can and remember to point
your knees
out close and point
give me three more
and point good job okay now give me few
half squats so remember toes pointer
forward stand in a neutral position
push your butt back
just slightly okay so we're not doing a
full squat just yet
just small squats
just to activate your quads
as well as your glutes
remember that your knees should always
be in line with your toes so do not push
them forward in line with the toes
and push your butt back
chest
up
so
look straight ahead good few more
last one more
and up all right okay now let's step
right at the edge of your mat let's get
into inch worms alright so
reach your arms down
with a slight bend in your knees slowly
inch forward into a high plank position
and slowly
inch back
and stand up good job now let's try it
again if you can keep your legs straight
and feel a slight stretch in your
hamstrings
reach forward into a high plank raise
your core and slowly inch back keeping
your legs as straight as you can up
two more okay
warming up the hamstrings
all the way forward high plank brace
your
core and back
plus one more
straight legs
high plank push into the ground
and slowly
inch
back
all right
get back into standing position so this
entire workout will be based on
repetitions and we want to aim for 15
reps per exercise the first round will
be focusing on your quads so your quads
are basically muscles located in front
of your thighs okay so we will be
breaking down your quads
your glutes as well as your hamstrings
which is located behind your legs so
let's first start on your quads so the
next two exercises i want to i want you
to really focus your mind
and your body
towards your quads alright goblet squat
if you have a weight grab a pair of
dumbbells and because your legs are
bigger muscle group you can go with
slightly heavier weights i would say
between five to seven kilos with goblet
squad
step slightly wider than shoulder width
apart
with your toes pointed forward place the
dumbbells in front of you okay if this
is too much what you can do is grab onto
one dumbbell directly in front of you
and all i want you to do is push your
butt back squat
get your elbows to tap your legs and
come back up so that's a goblet squat
and the load should be in front so down
push up
and feel the load on your quads
and up so two counts down one two
one count up good
push forward
up
so remember if you can get your elbows
to tap
your
thighs
up
do you feel the work on your quads
that's what we want okay the front of
your legs two counts down push up
back down
up remember to keep your chest upright
so do not lean forward okay chest
upright squat down control
up
give me five more down
up there you go
good
remember what are we working on your
quads
up last two more
down
push up
last one more down and up
very very well done okay the next
exercise is going to be forward lunges
so grab on to
both dumbbells start right at the end of
your mat what i'm going to do is step
your right leg forward
and push yourself back into standing
position and again the load should be on
the front leg okay so let's go forward
push your body weight forward push back
that's it so as you
step forward lean forward a little bit
push it back
feel the work on your quad
push
do your final balance remember
do not rush through the workout
let's get our form
right
lean forward slightly
but still keeping your back flat your
chest upright
push back good job
look at one focal point to find
your balance back
breathe out as you push yourself back
up
okay
keep going halfway there
give me seven more
push
push
six more remember to load the front leg
and push imagine that you're loading all
your energy and push it up
last five
push
load and push and try to get your back
knee
to touch the floor but do not harass
okay
that's two more
push
one more on each side
load
good job
pushing through your heels
and back down all right so
drop the dumbbells okay so we want to
repeat both exercises again remember the
focus is on
your front thighs okay
your quads
let's start with goblet squat once more
grab onto one dumbbell
place it directly in front of you okay
if you want to challenge yourself you
can go with heavier weights even up to
15 or 20 kilos if you want to
right step
slightly wider than shoulder width apart
toes pointer forward ready remember
push down
up
get your elbows to tap
and up
good job
so the whole goal is to slow it when
you're down
and speed when you're up okay use the
force to push yourself back up
up
very good tap
up if you're struggling you can always
do
half goblet squat and push yourself back
up
okay do not
hunch forward keep your back straight
down good job
give me five more
push
loading on the front
leg last three more push
that's two more
and one more let's go down and up very
well done okay
it's straight into front lunges so grab
on to both dumbbells okay
start at the end of your mat remember as
you step forward
lean a little bit forward and push
through your front leg ready 15 reps on
each leg let's go
lean forward
push
good job
keeping your chest up right okay
remember if you find yourself doing this
this is wrong chest up
back flat
and push through the front
heels
both legs should be
in a 90 degree position
push
10 more
good job
so we're not rushing or fighting against
time
in this workout
it's all about getting
the wraps in
and really
loading the right muscle
and getting
the form perfect
good job let's go
five more almost there
push
lean forward slightly push
good job
strong quads
last three more
push
two more let's go
one more
are we ready let's go down low push
that's one more
and up
drop the dumbbells
okay
very very well done
your heart rate should be slightly
increased as well and you should feel
all the work on your front quads if you
need to take a short break take a short
break keep yourself hydrated and in the
next round we want to focus on our
favorite part
your glutes
right
this round we want to focus on your
glutes so these four exercises are glute
specific workouts again just like what
we have done with squats and lunges it's
almost the same but we want to modify
the position to really hit on your
glutes so grab your dumbbells alright so
right now i want you to focus your mind
onto your favorite part which is your
glutes so the first workout is going to
be a sumo squat
step wider than shoulder width apart
okay toes pointed out just imagine that
you're in a sumo squat position place
both dumbbells in front of you and as
you push as you squat down push your
butt back push your knees out
and up so this workout works on your
outer glutes as well as your inner
thighs so remember to step wide
but
not too wide that you will lose your
balance okay so only wide enough that
you're still able to push up through
your heels
down and up same thing two counts down
one count up
remember focusing on your outer glutes
feel the stretch on your inner thighs as
well
give me ten more okay
down push up
look straight ahead
feel the load
on your butt
remember chest up
go down
up
are we ready five more
up as low as you can
feel the stretch on the inner thighs
good
four more
up
last three
same thing breathe in as you go down
breathe out as you come up
two more
push
one more down and up okay good job now
drop
one
weight okay
the next workout is going to be a side
lunge so start at the edge of your mat
all right so
grab the dumbbell in your right hand
set up
load and push yourself back up so
remember that the focus
should be on your glutes as well step
out keeping your legs straight
push
and
push
good job step up
knees pointer forward and
push
through
your right heels
can you feel the work on your glutes
your outer glutes as well as your under
butt keeping your left leg as straight
as possible
okay five more
push
good job
push
last three more push
two more brace your car look straight
ahead remember that neutral position
that i always mention that's what we
want one more
and push good change the other side
at the edge of your mat now let's go
with your left leg okay ready step out
right leg straight push
good job bend your left knees
push
place the dumbbell just
in between
if you find that you're struggling you
can drop the dumbbell
load on your left butt
and push yourself back up
so you have to really brace your car
use
the strength and power from your left
leg to push yourself up good job
give me seven more push
step out right leg straight
push
that's five more
[Music]
good
remember to keep your arms relaxed okay
three more
push
two more
up
one more step out
and in oh my gosh i am sweaty right now
okay now let's get down onto the floor
okay the next workout is glute bridge
probably one of our favorite workouts so
lie flat on the floor
keep your heels close to your butt in a
triangular position
if you want to start off with just place
one dumbbell
around your hips and all i want to do is
use the strength from your butt your
glutes to push yourself up okay
push yourself up squeeze for two counts
lower yourself down and before you touch
the floor push yourself up again
all right
if you feel that you're feeling more on
your hamstrings then you have to bring
your legs
back closer to
your butt good job control up squeeze
for two counts
back down
up squeeze there you go
hold it
squeeze hole
back down
give me
eight more down
squeeze so do not rest okay
imagine that there's something pulling
you through your belly button straight
up to the ceiling
working on your glutes
up squeeze
push through your heels
[Music]
squeeze
last four more
up very good
oh
glutes on fire that's two more
up
back down and
up
okay now drop the dumbbell
get back up we're still working on the
mat okay
get into all fours
the next workout is going to be a
straight leg kickback all right again
working on
mainly your glute maximus so what i want
to do is point your left leg straight
all i want to do is gently tap onto the
floor
push it up and squeeze it remember no
rotation on the hips so keep it in a
straight line up and squeeze down
up and squeeze you should also feel the
work on the under butt
good job
small movement but really effective
just to isolate the glutes
up
squeeze
ten more
squeeze
remember with every
workout you want to hold it for at least
two counts right at the top
squeeze
squeeze last five more
[Music]
push
good job three more
doing well
keeping your hips squared
last two more
tap and up one more
and up okay
rest the left leg now change side let's
go with the right side
extend your legs straight out and point
ready let's go up
there you go down
up squeeze pull for two counts
three
four good job
five very nice
feel it right at the glutes
six
small movement
seven
eight
try to kick higher nine but remember do
not overarch your lower back okay last
five more keep a flat back one
two
three
four that's one more
and five
oh my gosh
what a workout
i'm sweaty i'm feeling my glutes and
guess what we want to repeat the entire
round once more so
grab your dumbbells now that you are
more familiarized with the movement i
wanted to really
focus on your glutes and really target
every angle okay so step wide toes
pointed out
dumbbells in front in between your legs
ready let's go sumo squat
push
up
pushing through your heels
and up
what is the focus right here it is your
outer glutes as well as your inner
thighs
up good job
up ten more
remember
gaze
forward
2 2 comes down
up very good
pushing your knees
out
good
let's go
dig
deeper and go lower last five more
down
up
four more
up
stay with me
i know i'm feeling the burn but it's
good it's going to help you develop a
round butt
one more and
drop one dumbbell okay
are we ready for some side lunges start
at the edge of your mat remember we're
stepping out with your right foot okay
left toe
pointed forward are we ready let's go
only one dumbbell
push
good job loading on your right leg push
push your butt
back
okay
remember to push your butt backwards
load
and push
good job
as much as you can point both toes
forward
ten more let's go
eight
more kush
and just keep breathing okay
pace your breathing
now five more
back up reset if you need to and back
out
three more
i'm really feeling my legs here
last two stay with me okay
i know it's burning
and one switch the other hand
let's start right at this side of the
mat and pushing your left leg out okay
remember to brace your core suck your
belly in and keep yourself in a neutral
position ready let's go
push
good job
load the left leg and up
very good remember
your arms should not be doing
any work
at all okay
it's just
helping you
to add on more
tension
by holding on to a dumbbell if this is
too much you can drop
the dumbbell okay
good job halfway there eight more
straight legs
you should also feel
the stretch
on
your inner thigh right here
last five more
push
three more
that's two
good job
and one more
and up
okay
are we ready let's get down onto the mat
grab either one
or both dumbbells lie straight down okay
again just a reminder
if you feel that you're feeling more on
your hamstrings instead of your glutes
that means that you have to bring your
legs
closer to your body okay if you're
stepping too far out that's when you're
going to feel it more on your hamstrings
so remember
step your heels close to your butt in a
nice triangular position
all right
i'm going to go with both dumbbells okay
place two dumbbells on your hips are we
ready let's go
up squeeze two counts at the top lower
yourself down
up and squeeze
there you go
so what we want to focus on is the
contraction
right at the top
every rep matters so give me a solid
quality
wrap good job squeeze ten more two
counts up
down nice and controlled
up
so don't just let your butt fall flat
onto the ground okay
control every movement
good
six more
stay with me
i know it's burning but that's what we
want
that's how we keep progressing and
improving on our workout
that's four more
three
that's two more
and up hold it one two
three higher four five and drop
okay
now get back up
get into all fours
okay
you don't need your dumbbells for this
workout okay
get on to all fours
remember what we're doing straight leg
kick back all right so let's start with
our left side point your toes are we
ready up and squeeze
remember
keeping your hips squared
lower your legs down tap
up
feeling it on
your entire glutes but also the underbar
up
down up 10 more
up
good job
as you notice this workout is a lot
slower compared to all my other workouts
because this workout focusing focuses on
building your strength and it's very
specific on
a certain muscle group okay
up
last five more
up
so it doesn't work so much on your
cardio but it's more about working on
your strength
that's one more
and
up squeeze good job now change the other
side okay
right leg straight are we ready let's go
up squeeze
remember keeping your legs in a straight
line two
brace your core
try to keep a flat back four
five
tap onto the floor do not rest six
squeeze
seven good
eight push it up
nine
and just gaze onto the floor okay
keeping a neutral spine
we don't want to
basically put any tension on our neck
us
four more one
two
three
and four
very very well done
oh my gosh okay
that is the end of round two so we've
worked on our quads and our glutes and
for the final round the focus will be on
your
hamstrings
okay
this muscle right here at the back of
your leg so take a short break keep
yourself hydrated and i will see you in
the final round
[Music]
are we ready for the final round so we
have worked on our quads as well as our
butt what is left your hamstrings the
back of your legs okay do not neglect
this muscle because it's going to make
your entire legs look really full and
nice so there will only be two exercises
alright so again right now i want you to
focus your mind onto
this part just this part right here okay
so let's start grab on to your dumbbells
the first workout is going to be stiff
dead lift just like the word
try to keep both legs as straight as you
can okay just keep a slight bend in your
knees but as much as you can try to keep
both legs straight so again toes pointer
forward in line with your shoulders
drive the dumbbells close your legs try
to keep your legs as straight as you can
feel the pull on your hamstrings that's
what we want keep your back flat and
squeeze right up okay
you should feel the pull on your
hamstrings
and
up
you don't have to come all the way up
again we're not working on your glutes
we're working on your hamstrings
good
so the dumbbells should be close to your
thighs
and
up
that's it
okay how do you know if you're doing
this workout correctly do you feel the
stretch on your hamstring yep that's
what we want so dumbbells close to your
thighs all the way below your knees
up
if you're finding yourself doing this
remember this is wrong back flat
okay
look straight ahead chest up
feel the stretch as much as you can up i
do understand that some people have
tighter hamstrings as well as tighter
hip flexor so only go as far as you can
as long as you feel the stretch come
back up
okay so don't compensate on your forearm
give me seven more
down steep dead lift
straight legs
up
okay nice and controlled movement three
counts down
push up through your heels use the
strength from your hamstrings
up four more
down
up so again i'm pushing my butt back as
well as you can see i'm pushing my butt
back
up
straight
down
up
one more
down and
up all right good job now let's drop the
dumbbells let's get down onto the floor
similar like the exercise we did before
let's get
into a glute bridge position
again it's about changing your posture
to target different muscle group okay so
just like the bridge position what i
want to do now is tiptoe
all right and lift your butt up
throughout the entire workout what i'm
going to do is step out
step in
step out
and step in
do for your hamstring if this is too
tough place your heels down step out
feel the stretch on the hamstrings step
in
okay
remember what i said if your legs are
too far out that's when you will feel
your hamstring and that's exactly what
we're doing right now
stepping out
and
in i know this workout is not easy
final balance brace the core
and in push up
good job
give me five more
okay
really
extending forward
feel the work on the hamstring and
pushing it pulling it back
in
last two
more last one more
so choose your option okay either tiptoe
or drop your heels down
very good okay now let's get back up
into standing position
grab your dumbbells
okay
it's back to the first workout steep
deadlift so again remember
start in a neutral position
knees toes pointed forward in line with
your shoulders keeping your dumbbells
close to your thighs all the time
pushing your butt back keeping your legs
as straight as possible
go past and up
okay
so pass your knees
and
up
chest up
[Music]
and up good job keeping your back flat
okay it is very important to keep your
back flat
keep your shoulders open so do not hunch
down
up
remember
what are we feeling your hamstrings so
feel the stretch on your hamstrings
and
push
good job
down push your butt back straight legs
push
give me eight more
push there you go
hamstrings
something we often neglect
down
up five more
let's go back down
as low as you can okay
up that's three more down
up
two
okay don't rush through
every rep counts
and
up okay
drop the dumbbells
final workout
are we ready get into a glute bridge
position remember start with your heels
close to your butt
place your hands next to you
push into the ground lift your butt up
choose your option okay if you want to
start with your heels step forward
step back
so always
be conscious of your hip position
lift it
up okay do not dip your hips up
and step in
step out and step in okay
feel the stretch on your hamstrings
are we ready
to tiptoe let's go up
step
only eight reps okay
in
good job as high as you can
in
push
imagine that you're doing this
by wearing a pair of high heels push
that's four more
tip toe
last three more
up
two more
come on keep it strong
and up
and drop back
down
okay
slowly push yourself back into standing
position
all right
so
that is the end of your lower body
workout session we started off by
focusing on our quads and then we went
on to focus on our glutes and finally
your hamstrings so i hope that this
workout has taught you the basics of a
proper lower body workout and that in
the future if you were to perform lower
body exercises you will know exactly
which muscle you're working on and that
your mind will be fully in tuned and
connected to that particular muscle and
it is very important for you to know
that because that is how you can keep
progressing and for your muscle to keep
growing as well so i hope you enjoyed
this workout remember to end with some
quick stretches if you want to and i
will see you in the next workouts all
the best